much of course social distancing is
recommended by doctors and in many cases
it is ordered by state governments but
police say it is often nearly impossible
to enforce as Jonathan Vigliotti
discovered on a packed beach in Southern
California we met Los Angeles County
Sheriff Alex Villanueva after he took an
aerial view of Malibu's sweeping
coastline beach goers are not allowed to
sit down and also must wear masks though
we found most played loose with the
rules my only direction is just make
sure there's no big congregation of
people if they're pretty much spread
apart and they're not harming anybody
we're gonna call it a day despite the
order there was no crackdown the sheriff
weighing in on the side of beachgoers
because he says people need to come to
the beach to relieve the pressures of
the lockdown your staff is also called
at a release valve for families cooped
up in homes you know sometimes family
situations can be quite stressful when
you're packed in together for so long
very much so we saw increased taking
calls for service on domestic violence
domestic disputes but overall now that
we have some more opportunities
hopefully they'll start diffusing that
deputies on ATVs continue to patrol the
beach but did not confront sunbathers
authorities say enforcing social
distancing across the country remains
difficult as many of the orders are not
law in Florida Daytona Beach police
released video from this weekend showing
a sea of people the sheriff there
admitting there was little his deputies
could do social distancing is not a
crime it's an executive order issued by
the governor that no prosecutor state of
Florida has prosecuted anybody for that
and no judge is going to convict them
and back here in Malibu the crowd size
about one-third of what it was this time
last year the sheriff telling me he is
prepared to make arrests when people
aren't using what he calls common sense
Miguel so far he says he hasn't needed
to boy Jonathan I hope people don't find
out the hard way social distancing
matters thank you very much